DANA.
♪ ♪
IF HE COULD CHANGE A TIRE, MAYBE
YOU COULD CHANGE THE WORLD.
>> I'M CHANGING THE TIRE ON THIS
TRUCK.
IT'S THE ONE, THAT WENT GREAT.
IT BEATS WATCHING HIM CLIP HIS
EAR HAIR.
>> WHEN YOU DON'T GET IT CUT, IT
CAN BE NASTY.
>> Greg: YEAH, DRAGGING YOU TO
THE DENTIST TO SEE THE INSIDE OF
HIS GAPING MOUTH.
>> SO, I'M HERE AT THE DENTIST,
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE OUR
SERIES ON THE PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER.
>> Greg: SO WHAT'S NEXT FOR
SLENDER MAN?
WHAT OTHER IMPERSONATIONS OF A
REGULAR GUY CAN HE DO?
CAN HE HAMMER A NAIL INTO THE
COFFIN OF HIS DEAD CAMPAIGN OR
DIG A DITCH WHERE HE CAN BURY
THE UNSOLD COPIES OF
"VANITY FAIR"?
MEANWHILE, SHE GETS AN EAR FULL
OF REALITY FROM A FOREIGNER.
FARMER >> I
DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: THE TRUTH LEFT HER
COLD AS, LOVE FINDS NO.
>> OKAY.
I WANT TO MAKE YOUR HEALTH CARE
WAY YOU LIKE IT.
>> Greg: THEN SHE THREW HER
BEHIND BARS.
WHILE THAT WAS BAD.
NEITHER LIZ OR MARLA FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
THEN THERE'S TRUMP.
LOVE HIM OR HATE HIM, HE'S
ACHIEVED ONE GREAT THING.
BY COMPARISON, HE MAKES EVERY
POLITICIAN WHO STILL ACTS LIKE
ONE LOOK KIND OF FUNNY.
NEVER LET HIS UNIQUE PERSONALITY
BECOME SUBSERVIENT.
YOU'D THINK THEY'D FIGURE THIS
OUT BY NOW.
YOU AREN'T GOING TO BEAT TRUMP
WITH LET'S PRETEND WE ARE REAL.
YOU WIN BY BEING REAL.
TOO BAD THAT'S NOT AN OPTION FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE ONLY REAL PEOPLE THEY HAVE
SEEM TO BE IGNORED OR MOCKED,
LIKE MARIANNE.
THE OTHERS, COOKIE-CUTTER
CLONES.
HERE'S THE COOKIE MONSTER.
THE THING IS, DANA, EVERYBODY
JUST KIND OF LOOKS FAKE.
TRUMP BROKE THAT, AND IT CAN'T
EVER BE THE SAME, AND THERE'S
ONLY ONE PERSON ON THAT
BATTLEFIELD THAT CAN MATCH HIM.
AND I THINK WE KNOW WHO THAT IS.
>> Greg: MARIANNE?
>> Greg: MARIANNE WILLIAMSON.
SHE'S NOT PRETENDING TO BE
ANYBODY.
SHE'S THE REAL DEAL.
SHE'S FIGHTING A PSYCHOLOGICAL
BATTLE, WHICH MAKES ARE
DIFFERENT THAN ALL THOSE OTHERS.
>> Dana: THE INTERESTING THING
THAT YOU JUST SAID IS THAT THE
BACKFIRE IN AND EXPOSES THEIR ON
THE HEALTH CARE PIECE WITH
KAMALA HARRIS, IT'S LIKE, WAIT,
WHAT ARE YOU REALLY FOR?
AND HOW CAN YOU SAY YOU ARE
GOING TO DO THESE THINGS WITHOUT
MESSING ANYTHING ELSE UP?
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
HEALTH CARE TO A SENIOR CITIZEN,
THEY LOVE THEIR MEDICARE AND
THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT THEIR
MEDICARE WILL REMAIN THE SAME IF
YOU PROVIDE MEDICARE FOR ALL.
THEY NOTE THAT THAT ISN'T
POSSIBLE.
BETO HAS THIS PROBLEM OF NOT
LOOKING AUTHENTIC, LIKE A
GIMMICK.
LET'S PUT ASIDE WHAT HAPPENED IN
EL PASO.
BUT, THE STUFF THAT HE DID, LIKE
AT THE DENTIST.
AND THEN YOU HAVE WARREN.
HER LEFT-WING AGENDA IS PRETTY
MUCH DONE ON ARRIVAL OF MIDDLE
AMERICA.
IT IS TARGETING, ZEROING IN ON
THEIR BIGGEST VULNERABILITY.
WE WANT WHAT CAN THEY DO?
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY CAN'T FIGURE
IT OUT.
THEY ARE KIND OF IN A PICKLE.
>> THEY ARE IN A PICKLE.
THAT'S A GOOD WAY OF PUTTING IT.
I THINK ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS
THAT TRUMP DID WAS DESTROY THE
FAKENESS OF AMERICAN
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNING.
I HATE THIS BUSINESS WHERE THEY
TRY TO DEMONSTRATE THEIR
AUTHENTICITY BY, WE KNOW HE
DOESN'T CHANGE TIRES.
IN A VEHICLE THAT IT HAD ITS
TIRES DONE BY BETO O'ROURKE
ANYWAY.
WE WANT WHY A GERMAN AUTO WAY,
MARK?
>> Mark: I'M IN NEW YORK.
IT'S A CRAZY STATE IN MANY WAYS.
>> Greg: IT IS.
>> Katie: ONE OF THE THINGS
ABOUT TRUMP IS, IT'S A
BIPARTISAN THING.
I LIVE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
WE DON'T GET THE MYPILLOW ADDS.
WE JUST GET THESE POLITICAL ADS
ALL THE TIME.
I'M PROUD TO SAY I WAS BORN THE
SON OF A MAILMAN.
HE WAS A LEHMAN BROTHERS.
HE IS THE BROTHER OF A LEHMAN.
HE SAYS "I'M PROUD TO SAY I WAS
THE SON OF A --"
I'M PROUD TO SAY I GREW UP THE
SON OF A PRESIDENT.
WE HAD IT TOUGH ACT THEN.
TRUMP DESTROYED ALL THAT.
YOU CAN'T GO BACK TO IT.
>> Greg: YOU.
WHAT ABOUT, THE MOST AUTHENTIC
PERSON BEHIND MARIANNE IS
BERNIE.
HE'S THE REAL DEAL.
>> Mark: FIRST OF ALL, I'M
STUNNED.
>> Juan: HE IS NOW THE BIGGEST
FAN OF MARIANNE WILLIAMSON IN
THE WORLD.
THIS IS A TOTAL SET UP.
>> Greg: YOU ARE READING IT
INCORRECTLY.
>> Juan: I KNOW, BECAUSE I'M
ALWAYS WRONG.
HUMANIZING POLITICIANS IS
AMERICA'S APPLE PIE.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN THERE.
YOU DON'T TELL YOUR CANDIDATE TO
GET HUMAN, TO BE AUTHENTIC, YOU
ARE NOT A POLITICAL CONSULTANT.
IF SOMEBODY TOLD THE
DONALD TRUMP, "WHY DON'T YOU
HIRE SOMEONE TO STAND AROUND."
I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Greg: IT'S A TV SHOW.
IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A TV
SHOW FOR TRUMP.
BUT HE'S NATURAL.
HE'S NATURAL NATURAL.
>> Juan: A TACO BOWL ON
CINCO de MAYO?
>> Mark: THAT WAS DEHUMANIZING
DEHUMANIZING.
>> Greg: ONE, YOU KNOW WHO
TRUMP DOESN'T TALK ABOUT?
MARIANNE WILLIAMSON.
HE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT HER.
>> Dana: EARLY ON, I THINK IT
WAS AT ONE OF THE DEBATES, YOU
SAID, SHE'S THE ONLY ONE UP
THERE THAT IS ACTUALLY TALKING
TO PEOPLE IN A LANGUAGE THAT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND.
>> Juan: THE GOOD THING ABOUT
HER IS THAT SHE SAYS YOU CAN'T
OUTRUN ANYBODY.
YOU'VE GOT TO TALK TO THEM ON AN
EMOTIONAL LEVEL.
REMEMBER, SHE SAID TRUMP IS
DARKNESS AND HATRED AND YOU'VE
GOT TO COME WITH LOVE AND LIGHT.
>> Greg: THAT IS A COHESIVE
ARGUMENT.
>> Juan: BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT
PERFORMANCE.
>> I GET WHAT THEY WANT TO SEEM
RELATABLE.
REMEMBER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I THINK IT'S REALLY SAD THAT YOU
NEED CONSULTANTS TO TELL
POLITICIANS TO BE A HUMAN.
BUT I THINK IT'S SAD, BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE FINE IF BETO WERE OUT
THERE.
HE CHANGED THE TIRE THE WAY I
CHANGE A TIRE.
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS TO
EVERYBODY.
THEY ARE TRIPPING OVER THERE OWN
FEET TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEIR VOTERS WANT.
THIS ONE WORKED RUNNING AGAINST
SOMEBODY LIKE MITT ROMNEY.
I THINK IT WOULD WORK AGAINST
SOMEBODY WHO WAS A PROGRAM TO
CANDIDATE.
BUT THEY ARE RUNNING AGAINST THE
GUY WHO WON BY JUST SAYING
WHATEVER HE HAD TO SAY, BEING
HIMSELF.
SOMETIMES HE'S NOT POLITICALLY
CORRECT, SO IT DOESN'T WORK.
THEY SHOULD SPEND LESS TIME
TRYING TO DO THIS AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT, HEY, WHO ARE
RERUNNING AGAINST AND IF WE
ACTUALLY WIN, DOMINIC.
SAY WHAT HE'S GOT TO SAY.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY HE WALKS
UP BEHIND HILLARY CLINTON AND
LOOKS LIKE A --
HE DOES ALL OF THESE THINGS.
>> HE MAKES MISTAKES.
HE MAKES MISTAKES, ONE, BUT IT'S
REAL.
HE'S THAT DOMINIC GOT THAT FEEL
OF THIS IS HOW HE WOULD FEEL.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY WHEN I SIT
AROUND, I GET ALL THE WOMEN WHO